thank you
[Music]
in down under news
no that's a noise
that's a knife it's a crocodile boy my
government's very impressive mate I'm
trying
that's a terrible accident
yo what the [ __ ] hey what the [ __ ] man
this is my indigenous people dude
indigenous
all right so a um
Amer formation dude
a mayor of uh Australia married a
crocodile the mayor of Australia a mayor
a mayor a mayor not the mayor who is a
prestigious person
here on Australia right
crashes her car drunk driving oh tight
just after meeting families of drunk
driving victims
oh man that's a bad luck because after
she met them it was such an emotional
time she had to get drunk to shake it
all off and then she went home and
[ __ ] crashed dude how bad she didn't
even go home yet no she's with the
victims she's like hey this is [ __ ]
crazy I'm so sorry she's like
shots
she's like this is kind of a bummer you
guys want to drink no your stories about
your family is like really [ __ ]
depressing
so can we do some shots dude how funny
would it be if they like if you like hit
the families leaving the place
just on the way out and they're like oh
man someone's got to do something about
these drunk drivers [ __ ]
so residents are Furious over an
Australian mayor's drunk driving crash
just one hour after she met with the
families of drunk driving victims she
was already blitzed she was drunk with
them dude you get drunk in an hour
yeah maybe she did like five shots
before she left so she drank before
hey dude I'm not sitting here [ __ ]
going for [ __ ] 20 minutes hey
okay it just [ __ ] feels good I
understand she was drunk before she was
drinking with them during their whole
conference Redland city mayor Karen
Williams admitted to drinking quote
several glasses of wine I know right you
can always say wine because it's classy
it's a classic before crash
into a tree on Thursday night oh oh [ __ ]
and Australia has one of the world's
highest rates of car accidents caused by
drunk driving really really following
the United States well we have a bigger
population let's go you're gone
yo actually following the U.S Canada and
South Africa wait Canada too yes those
polite [ __ ] there's nothing to do but
drink okay so who's number one can we
can we see who's number one I think it's
us it's got to be us all I know is okay
yeah alcohol consumption is the key
factor in 30 of Road accident deaths in
Australia 30 whereas in the United
States the percentage is slightly higher
31 percent Ah that's nothing you got
them those are rookie numbers last year
as part of a one trillion dollar
infrastructure package Congress mandated
that automakers Implement technology to
prevent DUI deaths and in March
Tennessee became the first state to pass
a law holding drunk drivers accountable
for child support after a parent is
killed that'll teach him
I mean that's pretty good right it's
fine dude do you think it's gonna stop
somebody from drinking no it's not gonna
stop him but it might it'll help at
least this [ __ ] kid who's not
orphaned yeah you know what's gonna help
the kid
conflict oh
Steve hard work hardcore yeah where's
your compassion hey dude Batman became
Batman you know why because of drunk
driving because a bat broke his window
really though taught him a lot of things
that's the true origin story a lot of
[ __ ] I always wondered where the [ __ ]
whole bat thing came from yeah Pat broke
his windows scared the [ __ ] out of him
didn't he have like a giant bat cave
under his mansion He was like wandered
down oh no
he like Falls anyways dude Batman was
trying to pour orange juice in his
[ __ ] living room right and the bat
comes through the window and he's like
God damn what the [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah all over his [ __ ]
chiffon carpet he's like God damn this
[ __ ] seven thousand dollars oh my God
[ __ ] Alfred had to go scrub it out
and [ __ ] it's a yellow around that back
I love Bruce Wayne doing this at home
[ __ ] oh my God he's like I'll [ __ ] and
then he turns it into bat ears yeah
squeezes his head into a cowl he knows
it did Bruce Wayne's like I spent 50 000
went to zero
it's
also true
serious era of judgment and was deeply
regretful after her drunk driving crash
yeah no [ __ ] she stepped down from the
Brisbane Olympics 2032 board on Sunday
good however she's resisting calls for
her resignation she's resisting she says
I made a mistake I will learn from that
mistake I think politicians should get
double the punishment yeah
it's supposed to be a model citizen
you're supposed to be a piece of [ __ ]
every reduced sentence
deserve it reduces who are my
politicians I got Nancy Pelosi yeah
[ __ ] pocketing cash literally
pocketing cash for a lifetime of public
service
thank you thank you Nancy incredible
reduced Chuck Schumer we got Mitch
McConnell all these [ __ ] Legends
profiting for themselves off the public
time classic what about Joe Biden would
he do that would he do such things
you're present [ __ ] no he wouldn't yeah
you know what he wouldn't do take a
bribe ever ever literally ever he
probably doesn't even know what a bribe
is this guy he probably thinks it's
charity
and you know what you would never have a
son help him with any of that ever ever
ever especially not in Ukraine no or
China before the election I remember
seeing a very particular set of
photographs of his son oh yeah what was
he doing all kinds of hookers do a crack
and I was like put this cigarette out of
his lips and you know what I said to
myself
I don't trust My Lying Eyes
if if the New York Times don't confirm
this story it's all [ __ ] anyway they
don't have conspiracy because they don't
have an agenda the only people who have
this agenda is the Republicans in Fox
News and Fox News Fox News only them
that's it nobody else has an agenda so
that's and you heard it here first thank
you I live by that
shortly before the accident Williams had
declared quote we need to clean up the
drunk driving she called for a tougher
youth sentencing campaigning with the
families of a couple who was killed
along with her unborn child by an
intoxicated teenager a teenager in
January 2021
on Thursday afternoon she hosted a video
meeting with the families of drunk
driving victims one of the participants
was Judy Lindsay whose daughter Haley
was killed by a drunk driver over 10
years ago so she for sure I think I
empathize she she's having this
conversation with parents who other kids
she needs a drink she needs a couple
glasses yeah that's why she drunk drove
I think she deserved the drinks I don't
know if she
shot at least minimum one minimum dude
she was there for an hour though right
it was like that dude who got in trouble
in the UK prime minister or whatever for
like watching porn in a meeting at the
end of the day it's like dude number one
you got free internet yeah like some of
these meetings are boring you know what
I mean yeah
underside of your desk sometimes
you're great what did you just look at
right now the underside with this oh man
better give it hell sometimes you gotta
show his boss do you think there's gum
at the bottom of those [ __ ]
government desks that they're all like
when they have those um meetings and
[ __ ] and you got like [ __ ] all the
different countries and everyone's on
their [ __ ] thing right and then you
think there's gum underneath
you know I know that you know what I
know it's not underneath there
the galane Maxwell list
tell you that you know why because I
don't need to know I don't want to know
never never about that it doesn't matter
we don't need a question on government I
don't want to [ __ ] know it's gonna
cause too many Loops is that okay to say
R Kelly is having a heavier sentence
than by 10 Years bro or Kelly dude she
was hilarious because music was too
impactful that's why Glenn she had no
music Bart texted me that and I honestly
thought it was a bit and I laughed and
then I actually Googled it and I was
like God damn that's actually real
that's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] crazy but
then I was I also thought and I was like
I don't want to [ __ ] know yeah I love
celebrities
I love Hollywood I love my politicians I
don't want to [ __ ] with anything you
love your president that's like finding
out your dad's like a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you don't want you don't want to
know keep it to yourself yeah but you
find out they might be on the list
only my dad is that kind of money
[Music]